olá sou manuela e eu tenho 10 anos e
hoje vou falar um pouco mais sobre
energia renovável pra vocês vocês sabiam
que a principal que é a principal fonte
de energia atualmente usada no mundo é o
petróleo que ela é uma das maiores
responsáveis pela poluição no mundo e
pelo aquecimento global que esta fonte
de energia um dia vai se esgotaram
aí vocês pensam nossa qual é o soul são
para esse grande problema e eu respondo
energia renovável mas vamos começar até
o começo do que a energia é renovável
energia renovável é aquela originária de
fontes naturais que possuem a capacidade
de regeneração renovação ou seja não se
esgoto energia renovável solar a energia
renovável solar a energia extraída pelos
raios solares
usamos receptores próprias parece
trabalho
algumas pessoas colocam os receptores
nos quintais ou nos telhados de suas
casas
e uma curiosidade é que a energia
recebida pela terra é cerca de 5 mil
vezes maior e melhor do que o consumo
mundial de eletricidade e energia
térmica somadas energia renovável eólica
a energia renovável eólica é energia
obtida pela ação do vento
então a gente tem essa turbina que ela
está parada
enquanto a velha se encontra um convento
elas começam a mexer e um gerador
embaixo da turbina extrai aquele
movimento e transforma em energia
energia renovável hidráulica
a energia hidrelétrica energia que se
produzem barragens construídas em cursos
d'água é a mesma coisa que a energia
eólica só toada também têm turbinas aqui
dentro d'água paradas e quando a hélice
dessas turbinas se encontram com a água
elas começam a mexer em um gerador
embaixo extrai aquele movimento e
transforma energia energia renovável
brasil e no mundo
exemplo 1 a falta de chuva nos últimos
tempos acabou gerando o racionamento de
energia e por isso o governo brasileiro
está incentivando o povo a usar mais
energia eólica e biomassa em um shopping
da zona oeste de são paulo está ajudando
com essa iniciativa que está pondo uma
parte do seu teto de verde que extrai
energia renovável
exemplo 2 um baque na flórida apresenta
uma casa toda automatizada é de energia
renovável mostrando para várias famílias
que podemos viver à base desta fonte de
energia energia renovável conclusão a
energia renovável é inesgotável e não
prejudica a natureza como vimos existem
várias fontes de energias renováveis
mais limpas e sustentáveis
todas as características indicam ser
essa a opção a mais adequada para o
futuro da sociedade
depois de ter feito a minha pesquisa eu
pensei nossa como eu posso contribuir e
mora em um apartamento numa casa eu não
posso sair colocando receptores ou até
turbinas
então como é que eu posso ajudar depois
de pensar muito é descobrir uma solução
em vez de ajudar só na energia renovável
eu posso ajudar na própria energia
economizando água então eu procurei
desligar as luzes e as televisões dos
ambientes quando eu sair não vou mais
utilizá los e também estou usando a
pilha renovável que a matéria aqui
é recarregada e reutilizada para aí
vocês também podem ajudar nesse projecto
vem comigo vamos tornar o planeta terra
um mundo melhor
muito obrigada pela atenção de todos os
seres